les premières arrestations d'opposants
gazoduc coastal gaceline que la semaine
dernière ont donné lieu à des échanges
tendus entre ses chefs héréditaire des
oueds souhaitait et les policiers
oui demain
huit chefs se pose fermement au passage
du gazoduc costard gosling sur leur
territoire traditionnel qui n'a jamais
été cédé par traité à l'état canadien
l'intervention de la grc pour démanteler
des campements et des barrages et donc
pour eux ils légitimes et leurs
partisans membres ou non du web
souhaitait fonds distille acte de
résistance en entravant la construction
du pipeline et considèrent que leur
devoir est de protéger le territoire
28 d'entre eux ont été arrêtés depuis
jeudi pour avoir contrevenu à une
injonction leur ordonnant de libérer le
chemin les derniers barrages ont été
démantelés lundi
echostar gosling a annoncé la reprise
des travaux cette semaine le projet de
pipeline de 6 milliards 600 millions de
dollars traversera le nord de la
colombie britannique
il doit acheminer du gaz naturel jusqu'à
kitimat sur la côte pour l'exporter vers
l'asie la compagnie gazière souhaite
achever les travaux en 2023 costard
gaceline propriété de tessé énergie a
lancé ses premières consultations avec
les peuples autochtones en 2012
la compagnie a fait un bon travail selon
cet avocat en droit commercial qui se
spécialise dans la négociation avec les
premières nations pour le compte des
gouvernements et de l'industrie
le long du tracé du gazoduc 20 conseils
de bande incluant cinq conseils de bande
damnation et souhaitaient ont signé des
accords avec costa gatling leurs
dirigeants élus comptent profiter d'une
partie des 2500 emplois qui seront créés
pendant sa construction et de redevances
à plus long terme
mais les chefs héréditaire issu d'un
mode de gouvernance traditionnels ne
voit pas la chose du même oeil et se
considère comme seul compétent pour
choisir ceux qui traversent hors
territoire traditionnel ils s'envoient à
les gardiens ultime les conseils de
bande selon un love s'occuper seulement
des services données sur les réserves
cet anthropologue qui vit et travaille
auprès des huit souhaitait depuis plus
de 20 ans comparé les responsabilités
des bandas celle d'une municipalité leur
intérieur à mon avis le logement des
jeunes l'emploi les services sociaux
et ça c'est quelque chose que les chefs
faire déjà c'était c'était des choses
qui récupère mais ils ont tellement été
démunis de 1 politiquement
économiquement cuzon non plus n'ont pas
été capables d'être sûrement garder ses
responsabilités l'inquiétude est chef
héréditaire augmente à mesure que la
portion de leur territoire traditionnel
exemple de développement rétrécit
l'impact cumulatif de la foresterie de
l'agriculture et des pipelines met en
péril la pêche au saumon et la chasse
entre autres n'ont qu'à chaque fois
qu'un corps mais notre parti c'est c'est
un autre région du théâtre qui n'est
plus accessible pour les gens et aussi
sale un impact sur la nature légiférer
d'iter tombe depuis longtemps de faire
reconnaître les droits des oueds
souhaité m sur un territoire de 22 mille
kilomètres carrés avec les chef
héréditaire de la nation guide san ils
ont rapporté une victoire en cour
suprême du canada en 1997 dans la
décision delga mook contre colombie
britannique
le haut tribunal défini le concept de
titres aborigènes et reconnaît les
droits des peuples autochtones sur les
terres qu'ils n'ont jamais cédé
mais dans ce jugement qui porte sur le
droit et non sur les faits les juges ne
se prononce pas sur le caprice six des
huit souhaitait il les invite à
reprendre les négociations avec le
gouvernement provincial et fédéral
un processus qui n'a pas encore abouti